[Musique]
vous êtes dans la mezzanine isabelle
morini-bosc tout est dedans ça aussi on
n'avoue pas de ça j'adore mais j'irai à
lesmo louis dionne à quoi aujourd'hui on
a du monde adule aujourd'hui on a deux
gros dos alors sur un zapping un peu
spéciales es1 c'est quoi ta meuf on
adore c'est pas ta meuf fais pas ta meuf
exactement alors premier dos ouais
attention d'habitude j'ai reparlé
d'invités ou d'une émission bien sûr
puis je me suis dit ici là quand même
une personne qui a non pas une émission
non pas deux émissions mais trois
émissions du coup je me suis dit allez
un petit zapping spécial vous avez ma
bête prayols sur les émissions de la
personne c'est pas mon style et on
commence avec à prendre ou à laisser
avec des candidats qui se concentre et
un animateur qui les aide beaucoup à se
concentrer
[Applaudissements]
un animateur drôle brillantissime mais
avec avant tout très souple
[Rires]
et on passe direct d'ab château tenais
au crazy horse
[Musique]
vous êtes sur clairoix fota loi tout ça
sous l'oeil de l'huissier le plus sexy
du paf c'est qui est remise
ça commence mais bon c'est pourquoi pas
lui aussi là deux pompes on la voit très
peu souvent mais les deux salles deux
ambiances on passa btp avec un cyril
journalistes avec des invités sur
lesquels il a bossé didier poma comment
ça va
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
rattrapé par contre ne fait pas que
j'étais avec un didier gadou à nouveau
mardi pour les prénoms j'avoue c'est pas
facile facile mais sur les noms de
famille on est nickel dont on a
également julien borovick ski beau
audible julien bost c'est pas con c'est
vous la hausse crabe je suis bien on est
pas mal mais tp une émission sérieuse
avec des invités sérieux mais il faut
quand même des petites ban s'essaya
temmar a fait 12 mètres de long par
trois mètres de large ce qui fait 36 tu
nous sommes 35
ça fait deux mètres cubes par personne
mais un problème de chimie l'on dirait
caudéran canular pour piéger une
nouvelle fois rhône et une nouvelle fois
cyril hanouna ne sait pas garder son
sérieux et sa d'avoir accepté d'avoir
toujours que c'est sérieux fauquissart
l'installation d'un aux distributeurs de
canettes pour les équipes jeunes
cadettes c'est gratuit d'ailleurs on est
je crois qu'il serait pas contre une
petite canette ici
à
la dame est avec sa voix unique personne
de rallye du vtt seul monde au québec
vous sachiez dans btp quand vous sortez
une balle vous êtes seul au monde à la
c1 aura franchement là c'est tout sur le
titanic à renault mais pas bien alors
qu'on a on a on a du dos
on a du lourd exactement vous savez dans
l'art astra 5a une séquence qui
s'appelait c'est pas ta meuf mais
exactement il consistait à piéger des
mecs dans la rue en leur faisant croire
que leur copine embrassait mais maxime
gainey avait été excellent ben justement
et puis j'ai la pression j'ai essayé
d'être à la hauteur et maxime leur fera
également oui bien sûr voilà donc voilà
ce que ça donne ça s'appelle c'est pas
ta mais j'adore ça c'est exceptionnel
exception
[Musique]
je suis avec francky eléonore salut
salut a dû faire quelques instants vous
êtes ensemble huit ans hu et trois
premiers tests montraient bien vous avez
joué pour un petit bond illicado 200
euros donc c'est plutôt sympa ok donc je
pose des questions à toi sale année en
premier ça va tu n'écoutes pas tu vas
partir à ce qu'on en sait quoi qu'il
regarde bien cette carte parce que leur
bien et c'est quoi le petit surnom
qu'elle te donne dans l'intimité
ap ap le chercheur chacha au caire le
premier entre vous êtes parti en
vacances ensemble
dubaï est le truc le plus mignon que
t'es fait pour elle tu t'en souviens je
crois jeunes arbitres et un tour
d'hélicoptère ouais c'est pas ta mère
quoi c'est pas ta main car voilà
l'accès
vous êtes rencontrés comment alors on
s'est rencontré en boîte de nuit
je les ai vus j'ai mis sa belle
chevelure blonde je vais tirer les
cheveux est normale et utah débauche
mais donc j'ai tiré les cheveux
[Musique]
oh
au moins avec
[Musique]
[Rires]
des questions se renvoient tous ensemble
après d'accord non toi tu rates avec moi
parce que les questions
ça commence maintenant le truc le plus
mignon tu mets effet comme cadeaux des
fleurs ou vote de chocolat et un voyage
appelle moi des moyens sa plus grande
qualité poursuit son plus haut ce matin
[Rires]
on s'est rencontrés on s'est rencontrés
par un ami commun en soirée parce que tu
connais son dessert préféré
elle est très gourmande je sais pas
c'est quoi le cadeau le plus mignon que
tu lui acheter c'est peut-être ma
demande en mariage
ce catamaran
[Musique]
dans un gala
attendait de bons parce que là on a
[Musique]
[Rires]
comment vous êtes rencontrer rapidement
c'est toi qui l'a draguée si elle quitta
vrai n'y est pas c'est moi qui dès son
plus gros défaut labeaume un homme tronc
tu attends quoi ta meuf et les minutes
et on peut viser je vais pas me dire
mais alors dans le trou
[Applaudissements]
chaque année les chiens